thank you
the prophet Muhammad
told us whoever builds a mosque for
Allah Allah will build for him a Sim at
the house in Jannah and we know the
great reward that will not only be
gained but rather will fill your grave
after your death whenever someone prays
there whenever someone gives shahada in
the Masjid whenever someone learns
something in the Masjid yes that will be
something that you'll have on your scale
the Swedish shoe shiner rasamson
whatever his name is has come out again
has come out again yes he has come out
again now this time trying to attack a
person who he wouldn't be able to even
be in the same space in let's take a
look at what he has said now the Quran
is burning
the fault of smart
chechnya and wrestler and and also the
fault of the leader of chechnya if they
had learned to behave it wouldn't be
necessary to burn the Quran in front of
the Russian Embassy you know I dare you
uh shoeshine I dare you to go and say
that to his face you wouldn't say that
to his face you wouldn't challenge him
he wouldn't challenge any Muslim this is
a weak and cowering stance from you
isn't it you're such a coward aren't you
why don't you just admit it to yourself
to admit it to all of us you're a coward
aren't you
huh
anyway we've used you last time and
we're going to use you again how are you
gonna
how are you going to use them I'll tell
you how you go
since last time I made a video about you
I made a video about you and I used you
yes
we raised 75 000 for that mosque and
that dollar sent to 75
000 hmm
and what they're doing in that place
they're going to be praying they're
going to be saying they're going to be
saying the Adan it's going to be in
Scandinavia not only that they're going
to be teaching people Islam they're
going to be bringing people to Islam
they're going to be teaching people how
to memorize the very Quran that you
think you're burning isn't it ironic
therefore that every time you burn the
Quran you're producing more people who
memorize it
it's ironic
oh my God this is if anything this is
miraculous the more you burn it the more
you burn the book The more you burn the
book The more people memorize the book
and you know what's going to happen
today inshallah with the with the help
of the people we're going to reach 100
000 at least
so that we have not just gotten angry
but that we have taken action as the
Muslim Community against you action
which is effective which is longevus and
which has lasting change on the
landscape of the very area which you
inhabit Scandinavia I don't ever think
that giving money for the sake of Allah
you're losing it don't ever think that
we are people like the Muslim ummah one
of the things that make us the strongest
is that we are able to put money well
our money where our mouth is I say we
have to do this now let's reach 100 000
Don late to the link below to the
Scandinavian uh mosque and Dao Santa
make this man make this man show this
man and people like him people that
support him people that are on his side
that you try and hit us you try and
embarrass us not just political action
it's not just noise on social media but
it's Financial economic action which we
will retaliate with with salaam alaikum
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slam net from Norway are
establishing a mission a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the world even
greater so give gen generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even more